[Music]
all right all that beauty aside of what
of what you've accomplished here okay
let's talk politics for a little bit yay
do you have a label that you put on your
snow I think I labeled myself a
libertarian years ago I think a lot of
people use that I uh I forget what
moment it was there was uh someone asked
me actually someone bombarded me with a
question about wealth distribution
redistribution and I was just really
caught off guard and I didn't know
because I wasn't really at that time and
I would even argue now
well well-versed in that right that
taxation is wealth and and that like
that big big push so I don't know I just
I just consider myself pretty liberal on
things like gay marriage trans rights
and bathrooms stuff like that and pretty
pretty pretty conservative when it comes
to business taxes things like that yeah
that's it so almost every seemingly sane
person that I meet these days says
something along those lines I'm socially
liberal and I'm fiscally conservative
now of course there's people on both
sides of that that does I think I think
what I've seen myself labeled like so a
lot of people say I'm a lot of different
things I think the closest thing I've
seen is I'm a moderate a moderate
free-speech liberal that's the closest
thing I could be like okay I mean that's
fine I mean it doesn't matter because
the moment you have a liberal in there
there's a good amount of people that are
gonna automatically dismiss you same as
there'd be a good amount of people if
you said you were a Republican yeah so
that's why I just go like I don't know
yeah are you saying I haven't done the
perfect job in cleaning up the word
liberal didn't convince everyone Haskell
liberal it did News Center I didn't get
there with every single person is out
you're telling me never have work to do
no one no one ever knowing it will find
and I mean those the words are gonna
change the labels are gonna change I
don't know I just I don't want to stomp
down on people's rights and I don't want
the government in every facet of my life
right that's it Yeah right there's a lot
of holes you can poke into a very broad
statement
but when it comes to generalities I
think that's where I lie specific issues
I might have like a weird outlier
situation but otherwise yeah yeah so I
know you voted for Gary Johnson in 2012
did you publicly say who you I did not
voted for this year you didn't publicly
say no I didn't vote for either the main
- but you're also not saying you voted
for Gary no I'm not saying yeah all
right so we don't I mean I was
disappointed by Gary Johnson as far as
like the way he was perceived by the
public and his responses to it I think I
think that if there was ever a chance
and I I hate saying it because I've met
I've met him we had him on for the 2012
election he's one of the nicest guys in
the world's great that agree was so cool
but I was I was really disappointed
because it ended up being this
opportunity for a third party to stand
up in some meaningful way and it felt
you can blame the media all you want the
moments happened right you didn't have
to take certain things out of context
it just looked bad it looks like a
sideshow which is really unfortunate
because I think there are a lot of like
people a lot of really smart people a
lot of passionate people that that
believe in that of being a libertarian
the numbers weren't great the whole
perception wasn't great will there be a
chance in the future yes but it's not
going to be in 2020 everyone's solutely
everyone's gonna be voting hard and in
2018 but also 2020 yeah in the month
that I've taken off it seems to me that
that although I didn't think the chasm
could have gotten bigger it seems like
it actually got bigger just even in the
month
well what's fun for me is just seeing
though it's almost like it feels like
the WWE in a sense right there are
people rooting for people they didn't I
think before like I saw some of my like
super left friends like for a moment
being pro banning on some things and and
the same thing with with the Attorney
General people just like flip-flopping
go an issue to issue throwing out there
there there some some misconceptions
some of there where they were
predisposed on people for this specific
issue and so that's been really really
interesting I think there there's still
a lot of people that are hardline
but as far as the people that are a
little more Center seeing seeing some of
the way that flows has been so
interesting yeah how big do you think
the fringes actually are because it
seems to me we're constantly being the
conversation is being just driven by the
franchise I mean so just just in my last
day background so now it seems like this
white nationalist thing is now sort of
regained some traction or whatever it is
and I find it hard to figure out well
how do these people of real attraction
is this a real group of people or is it
5,000 people with no influence or is is
this making headway into our political
system or any of that you know I think
it's I think it's hard to tell because
right our perception is reality and I
think a lot of people their perception
is that it is like two groups of like
not equal size but everyone's up some
sort of extreme right so everyone's
either anti-fog who are attacking people
right or everyone's a white supremacist
that's running people over with a car
right and there's a lot of people that
that are in the middle there now I think
when it comes to Charlottesville and
like I know so a section of your
audience they're not going to be happy
with it but if if if I was if I was
there for the for the lulz if I was
there for the memes or I was there
legitimately for the statue
I would potentially have some issue and
personally want some separation to the
people throwing out like Nazi salutes
right to the to the people chanting old
Nazi slogans like that's there's a point
where I'm like I'm gonna peace out right
and I think that there were people like
that right 100% but you can't deny
seeing that number of people there for
for some completely shitty reasons yeah
right that's I think that freaked out a
lot of people you can say the numbers
being you know kind of blown out of
proportion
you can I think validly argue that we're
seeing the rise in Part two people
filling a role that the media has said
existed and so they're just filling it
up but there's I mean there's a real
there's a real issue with that yeah well
that's the part that I think is hard to
decipher how much is real versus how
much is these
that that led this thing and again I'm
just back on the grid so I haven't even
read enough about this specifically but
like how much is just them doing exactly
what will get the media to cover them
exactly what will get their videos to go
viral exactly what will get the more
Twitter followers and all that nonsense
and as someone that was just off the
grid seeing us led by all the online
stuff now right particularly dangerous
to me right oh yeah well I mean I think
because extreme reactions to extremism
just it just it's cyclical 100% I mean
you start seeing the KKK you start
seeing them right next to two white
nationalists and then you have that that
poor woman that was hit by that car
I mean murdered and then all of a sudden
for some people that's gonna make them
go well anti-fog what they did here it's
not that bad it's just a reaction right
and we started off into this
justification but then we get stuck in
these these constant comparisons of why
if you can't prove that someone is in
the wrong then you're just gonna prove
that the other person is also wrong
right and that gets us nowhere and it's
and it's extremely frustrating and I
understand it because it's an emotional
response it's it's it's kind of once we
were like we were talking about it's
like a punch to the brain but I don't I
mean if you said how do you how do you
make it better I have no idea
I have zero clue on how you make it
better well I think you make it better
by pretty much doing what you're doing
which is giving room for a lot of this
stuff so hopefully hopefully okay
try and try to do that is there ever a
video or a story that you cover that you
think you completely screwed up like
looking back it's probably that you
really I live within like kind of a
36-hour window like before we were even
filming and I was trying to talk about
some of my past and I was just like I
have to like look off and try and
remember I mean I think part of that is
me trying to suppress stuff yeah but I
have really I live within a 36 hour
window so if I rightly get called out
for something i 100% want to look into
it because my goal is not to always be
right my goal is to to try and tell the
truth and to also grow personally yeah
and it seems to be working so far from
what I can I'm like a
little older I'll be locked down and all
my beliefs and that's just who I'll be
until I die
that would be an interesting shift in
the business and in the content
yeah the new slogans gonna be [ __ ]
everyone I'm right what do you make of
this Trump gay we haven't said his name
this whole time no well no he's not
Voldemort
it's not it's not like that when people
think I mean there are people who
literally don't want to mention his name
they're giving him the Voldemort effect
well I think yeah I think when you make
the big claims Trump's a racist right
you automatically invalidate your
argument so like 50% of the people
you're talking to can he do things that
is going to negatively affect a lot of
people that aren't his skin color yes I
think that certain times I think that he
wants his way so much that sometimes
he's not going to care that maybe the
Constitution gets in his way
but I think we also see that with other
world leaders is it this level of
extremism or more importantly is it more
in our faces every day right when I wake
up every morning at six o'clock I know
that Trump's probably tweeted an hour
ago about something today it was that he
was going to I think it was on allow for
larger purchases with for South Korea
and and Japan as far as military
equipment and so I feel like it's just
more in everyone's face right we
wouldn't see the past president saying
like Dhaka exclamation mark so I think
I'm not saying that it's it's right or
wrong right a lot of people that support
Trump see that as the best tool in the
world they don't have to wait for an
official fancy stupid press conference
they're just they're being told for the
from the person they voted for
immediately write text straight to my
phone so I think it's just more in in
everybody's face
and so I think I mean he's a polarizing
guy like we I mean a lot of people don't
want like don't talk about in the same
way but to a lesser extent Obama is a
very polarizing guy to a certain section
of people I think you don't realize that
a lot of people are just on the other
end of that this time yeah what do you
make of just sort of the way everyone
deals with it so yeah you know you wake
up any given morning you know he's going
to tweet something crazy
I don't think that ever I've really gone
after one of the tweets specifically
because it just seems like such theater
and sideshow to me like they're all like
I'm a firm believer that pretty much all
politicians especially at that high
level they're lying either by omit like
there's just a system of half-truths and
omissions constantly right and yes Obama
lied the way that we liked presidents to
lie or or said that you know like red
line which was a lie that I think the
red line in Syria that even though I
didn't want to go to war in Syria you
laid out the red line then right or
you'll be a doctor no matter what you
can keep right that so that's a more
specific example right you can keep your
doctor right they knew it was a lie and
they still did it but he did it in the
in the sort of you know wearing a suit
speaking nicely giving long speeches the
notion of this that like they lied in a
certain way Trump's just lying in a
different way it's gross and disgusting
and I care about ideas and thoughts and
all that stuff so I don't want the
conversation to be about this but I just
see it as a different version of also
different versions are lying so I see
that but I also go like there's also
something a little bit defending it by
the way and I just see it's not like at
a cue for that ya know cuz I think
you're making me think that yeah the
main difference then is that you have
someone that's lying in a different way
but at the same time half of their
shtick is saying that other people are
lying right and so like that that's like
a different layer like I talked about in
the past but several times like
literally in tweets where he's saying
this is fake news it what he's saying is
a lie and I think that's I think that is
a prime example of some of the stuff
that's like really messed up and wrong
I'm not someone that wakes up going like
[ __ ] Trump right how am I gonna skewer
the guy today and I end up finding
myself having to defend them when they
get attacked for stupid things like when
people went after Melania Trump cuz she
wore high heels right and they're like
they're gonna go to they're gonna go to
Texas because a hurricane Harvey I'm
what you're gonna do in heels what's
what's the what's float is gonna do
right whether it's whether it's Melania
or any other any other person effort
like it's it's just frustrating
it's there's there is a reason to be
bothered by a lot of the stuff that's
happening and I think the place I find
myself the most frustrated is
the things that are illogical or don't
matter right yeah so and we're slammed
with those those are the ones were
slammed well and so in that's right
that's kind of like the the problem is
when when you stress out about these
minor things and you give them
especially because of a 24-hour news
cycle or the fact that so many of these
these organizations are so competitive
and they're giving things that don't
matter airtime compared to when they
really mess up and it is a really big
deal you just take away how important
the other thing is right and and you
won't and you end up just kind of
hurting your own argument when you have
the stronger argument because you're
complaining about everything yeah how
much do you think social media is just
adding to the craziness I don't even
mean Trump's Twitter but I mean just the
general like just as I'm getting back on
like just looking at that and seeing how
the same people fighting about the same
things and it's like does any of this
matter does any of this well then you're
gonna just end up in some like
existential yeah right I mean my whole
view on life is that none of this kind
of matters while I exist and what I try
and provide for like my family and
everyone I interact with I hope that I
put more good into the world than I take
but as far as as far as does any of it
matter the bickering I don't know part
of its part of its WWE [ __ ] fate
like not fake fighting but like
meaningless fighting and then there's
the stuff where lives are gonna be
affected right so when we talking about
Dhaka today right that's that's like a
real thing now everyone complaining
about it online no that's just noise
right but then at the end of the day
you're talking about real lives a real
impact right so some of it matters but a
lot of it does not it it's the it's the
beauty and the downfall of giving
everyone a massive megaphone yeah and
I'd rather have it this way I'd rather
have everyone have the chance to get
their voice out but of course that does
that does come with some stuff who are
likes just some people in general or
organizations that you trust because I
get that one all the contras any one man
no I don't I uh well when you're when
you're doing research and you've got
your guys looking at stories and
everything like everywhere you look
everywhere even when we provide links to
sources we don't even include everything
we trying to get as
as many different viewpoints and ways
that something's covered as possible
because sometimes they're places that
miss things maybe they omitted it maybe
people just think they omitted it and
then there's a completely different
viewpoint of a completely different
angle and my goal is to kind of as much
as I can cover a little bit of both
sides in the sense of at least
understanding where the angles coming
from even if I massively disagree with
it but I mean as far as like if we
talked about individuals I don't know if
I would automatically say trust where I
respect or I'm interested in obviously
like I'm doing this so you to an extent
to a fact everyone knows that you're
crazy communist no I uh we were talking
earlier ben shapiro always fascinated by
what he's gonna say or was kind of like
a viewpoint and then a few others that I
don't want on a call by name but yeah
isn't that funny you don't want to call
them out by name even though you'd be
probably saying something nice about
them but I get it cuz then it puts this
odd pressure right but then it's like oh
you've endorsed them and now they screw
up tomorrow it's like well especially
because you don't know everything about
every single person right they can be
like well in 1999 never like well
apparently I'm a Nazi now yeah
what do you do to get out of the the
mess and the matrix so so as I have a
week and a half ago I I've recently
started writing my well real bike and
then also a cycling bike it's the only
way that I can get energy anymore since
I am way too overweight and I've stopped
taking adderall a long time ago so it's
like it's like this beautiful burst of
energy so like right after we're done
here
I'm gonna go home knock out 45 minutes
slowly slowly gonna make my life a
little better both mentally and
hopefully physically does adderall lead
to jump cuts which came first a dural
eardrum cut the jump cut yeah the jump
cut the the adderall I think I think it
was right before I did my first tour I
initially got just because I was having
a hard time multitasking but I think
part of that was probably just I was
putting too much on myself
but it's so incredibly easy to like it's
it's incredibly habit-forming and the
first month that I stopped taking it it
was it was like moving through water
yeah it was rough do you have a DD or
something or you I was I was prescribed
the medication and so they said I did
but I think if you ever go to a doctor
it's one of the most over prescribed
medications easily although I will say
in California they're a little weird
about it like you can only go month to
month whereas in it all right yeah
whereas in Atlanta you could get like
several months I don't know if the law
has changed but that was that was the
biggest difference and I was like you
guys are letting people smoke weed and
you're freaking out about this Lana
which was so the reason I say it like
that is it was so alien to me because I
had lived in a place where it was
obviously illegal right you are okay
with weed yeah yeah I don't smoke it
anymore just because I feel like
especially now I'm like always having to
be in dad mode I'm like it's so weird
I'm so stressed about something going
wrong yeah so I should probably smoke
that but I'm worried that if I smoke I'm
not gonna be like there to be able to
handle the situation yeah and so that's
why I've like stopped speaking of dad
mode as you might have a second kid
while we're right now so your wife puts
up DeFranco family videos and I assume
the new baby will be involved in this
well there's at least probably yeah
we'll probably be there yeah how do you
where do you try to draw that line of
like how much of what you guys do is
public versus private - should come to
you and talk about any of this stuff
yeah well anyway the thing is like we
don't we don't share a bunch it's
usually I feel like she puts a lot of
work into the editing and I'm like
really proud and impressed because I
don't do any of that for myself anymore
yeah but no I mean I think it's gonna be
a bigger part of the conversation as our
oldest gets older because I mean we've
YouTube's been around long enough there
have been family vloggers that of now
like the kids grow have grown up and
they're like a big part of the vlog and
it is definitely different I know and I
don't wanna mention them by name but
like there are YouTube families that
have had to remove their kids from
school right because people were showing
up to the school trying to either see
them or take them
and you also have to take into account
if the kid actually wants to do it right
and making it and if it's what mom and
dad are doing not making it so they
don't feel guilty if they don't want to
because I've seen examples of that as
well and that's not even taken to
account that you're part of a family
vlog and then you're going into school
with people that are watching your
family vlog and so it can make you like
a celebrity but if something horrible
happens where something happens with
your parents everyone's gonna know about
it yeah so I don't know I think I like
sharing it because or I like seeing it
because I loved that all of a sudden I
saw a little gif of my son when he was
six months old and I was like oh I think
I know what video that's from and I got
to watch this video of my kid now I
could do that personally it seems like
such a weird alien thought of why would
I edit a video that I don't put out to
the public or share because and I'm not
trying to be cliche or corny in that way
but when you get used to sharing it with
people at it almost ends up being like
an extension of family extended family
but family where it's but it does have
this potential to become everyone
criticizing your life it's why I never
fully jumped into I'm going to be a
full-on vlogger because people talking
about me is completely different than
people talking about they them thinking
that my my that my opinion is garbage
right completely different extremes yeah
all right wait you gave me a couple
things sorry no I want to back I I
ramble through all my thoughts no no no
that was that was good but you said
something sort of you kind of had a
throwaway there that I thought was a
great moment
that you don't do any of your editing
anymore no must have been a beautiful
beautiful moment I mean I know for me
that when I've been able to take certain
things off my plate and give it to my
team or just add different things or
focus more on writing the direct message
river-like then I get to do what I'm
supposed to be doing that must have been
a beautiful moment is so scary
ya know it was so scary cuz the way that
I used to edit the show so you were
talking about jump cuts I would
literally say a sentence see if it
worked
say a sentence see if it worked as I
edited in iMovie and I think I term I
think I yeah I recorded directly with
I think the iMovie camera at first or
something I had connected that could
read that camera and yeah I would just
sup guys welcome to the show okay
completely horrible process like it's
why the tone is different in the old
videos but I felt like I had control at
the time I thought it was like I was my
editing something special and the moment
I introduce people are brought in an
editor it was the best thing in the
world because it does for you up to just
focus on that yeah all of a sudden the
videos can be longer you can focus more
on the creative make sure or now
fact-checking how do you ever worried
that you're gonna hand them something
and they're editing your words that you
know they're gonna mangle something or
behind the fear plot well I mean I
always review oh my god yeah no I'm uh I
try to at least like even today I was
like guys we got to do this early I got
to get out get everything up but no I
mean I'm sure my editors have like a
[ __ ] fill folder for like if it's ever
like you're fired all of a sudden
there'd be like three minute long
montage of me saying like lines that I
ended up going and cut that but no I
mean it's it's you have to open yourself
up it'd be a little vulnerable
especially once you bring people into
the process because especially with what
we're talking about I feel like I don't
know about you but I'm a little fluid
with my thinking on some things and so
like as I'm covering it I'm trying to
digest the whole situation and so as I'm
filming my opinion might change on
something fresh especially if some new
information comes out so and that's also
you have to worry about that because
then you're doing something based off of
information that's not fully updated
right and then you know damn well sure
that someone's gonna find it five years
ago saying god he said that it was the
reverse yeah and it's like well yeah I
evolved how about that yeah well that's
what every now and then I'll get into
like an argument with someone and
they'll be like look at this video you
did seven years ago where you said this
kind of off-color thing and I was like
well one you took it out of context to
just kind of I was kind of a dick I
would say things I thought were like
super edgy and and that's how you make
jokes and it's just horrible
like not like I saw something in a video
that you did for many years ago
something about B
the type of feminist you are something
and and you had some joke about saying
but it was like some sex joke about
women are saying like it was just a joke
and maybe I don't even remember exactly
what it was but it was like I saw
somebody attacking you over it and it's
like there's always something I don't
know I don't know what the specific was
so I'd be able to like comments on that
specifically because of my 36-hour
memory but I had 36-hour memory these
days is actually quite long for what's
going on in the real world
all right let's shift a little bit
because so this episode so I've been
trying to get you on forever and we had
to get schedules to match up and
everything but learn Liberty who's one
of our partners did partner up with us
to do this and when when they usually
send us professors or something you've
never worked with flarin Liberty earn
any contact with them ever but they said
to me if Phil wants to do the show we'd
love to sponsor the show and I said that
to you and you said immediately whatever
they were gonna they give like an
honorarium to our guest usually it's for
travel sometimes people come in from
other countries or whatever but you said
immediately I don't want the money
I want the money to go to the PKD
Foundation oh yeah the place you are so
yeah so I want to talk about that a
little bit so tell me about PKD and why
you care about it well I care about it
for two reasons my dad has it
PKD is polycystic kidney disease
essentially to kind of simplify it
your kidneys are eventually going to
fail and and so my dad had it he ended
up losing function and his kidneys got
to be on dialysis for a while I have it
so and my kids could have it because
it's it's passed down through great
carriers like myself but no I mean it's
it's it sucks I don't know I always I
never know how to talk about it because
it's such a depressing thing to me and
and I always try and put that stuff out
of my mind and think that I'm life's
never gonna catch up with me but no I
mean it's just people's kidneys are
gonna fail it affects a lot of people
pica dqr is
out there trying to help fund research
therapy Kady walks and I also just
didn't want to take your money well they
wouldn't have been giving the money to
me by the way they give it to the guests
so but I want it I wanted to be on here
for uh I don't it sounds weird but if I
took money for being here it'd feel
dirty I want to be here yeah the record
we don't pay our guests ever this is
just when the Liberty does things you
know why you lie why you lie today or
something you know we have to we have to
why you lie and a we have to have some
drama so that you actually alright so so
we can boost each other we should create
drama all right let me figure out ways
we can finish with a little drama I'm
excited for your dis track yeah here we
go let's try to create some drama do you
think the social justice things just
imploding all together I think it's what
we say about talking about generalities
yeah I think I think I think there's a
problem right moving to California
pushed me more Center being online and
seeing how like how crazy things were
getting as far as if things you would
label SJW right that pushed me more
Center talking in a video six years ago
and using the the wrong pronoun pronoun
accidentally on a story about a trans
person pushed me more Center and and
further not even Center just pushed me
away yeah and when you see things like
we covered the oh I'm gonna mess up her
name the the trans mono who has just got
booted from a lore'l campaign because
she went on this rant where she said
like it's all white people white people
violence and then she said she was taken
out of context because she was talking
around the events of Charlottesville and
it's like no you can let's say it's not
even in a vac or it's in a vacuum or
it's not
you're still no matter if someone's an
ally you're still using this this
all-encompassing language and you can
try and justify it but it ends up
pushing people away right people that
could be your allies and I'm not saying
tone yourself down for for people to
like you right just understand that if
you're gonna use all-encompassing
language that it's it's gonna it's not
great it's not great for your cause but
as far as is it imploding I don't know I
mean as far as generalities I'd hope
that people stop
ridiculous but care about actual people
right I think that's the goal right I
think that it then becomes this [ __ ]
crazy toxic thing where you have what is
it Evergreen State University where you
have place like that of students going
up to a teacher and and saying that
because he's talking with his hands
which oh my god I would be committing a
hate crime that's a microaggression
see this is how you do it that's insane
it's insane
we're just it doesn't need to be that
extreme yeah well I guess by imploding
that's what I meant that the hysteria
and those types of things are they're
just pushing good people Center which I
think ultimately is actually good so
yeah there's always going to be a
certain amount of hysteria right on both
extremes of course but that the more
there is the more you make decent people
you know a guy who accidentally screws
up a pronoun who who isn't a trans Fobo
or anything like that it makes them
really wait and go maybe this isn't
exactly where I'm supposed yeah by being
extreme you make extremists like that's
it's it's something we said earlier and
it's just it's just true in my opinion
yeah oh these are all your opinion just
my opinion ah leaving the door open
things with that don't believe in the
door open yeah I feel we should finish
on on free speech in general because I'm
gonna say it once and you'reyou're a big
free speech guy right you basically I
think you're a free speech absolutist
right is there I think so yeah I'm
trying to think I was like I'm so
intrigued by the thought and I think
I've heard your opinion on it of because
because people are going around and they
have the swastika zone because it is a
symbol for like this this horrible group
this horrible thing that that somehow
then changes the conversation on free
speech what are your thoughts so I'm
just hearing this literally just as I
just got back on I read one article
about this this morning about this idea
that these ideas are so inherently
linked to violence right right that day
in and of themselves around that the the
image or the words that these people are
saying I don't agree right don't agree
it sucks
as I've mentioned many times I had
family members on both sides my family
died in the Holocaust I grew up around
Holocaust survivors so this is not
something that I hold lightly any what
the
people were doing in Charlottesville any
of this these are disgusting people that
are doing this do they have the right to
say and do horrible things actually the
Supreme Court has affirmed right that
right with you know the March in
Illinois so it sucks like it doesn't
feel good you know you mean like we all
want to say something to you that make
me feel good about yeah [ __ ] these guys
and get out there and punch your not see
you know like like all these quitter
warriors want you to punch Nazis but you
know they never do it but they all want
you to punch them all at least to have
Touche Touche
but it doesn't feel good but I don't
want to trade something that doesn't
feel good to sacrifice what I believe is
right most important thing here which is
free expression and I think you hit only
a really good point is it doesn't feel
good and that's why it's one of those
things of when you say a free speech
absolutist and I'm like yes but this one
thing has me feeling dirty now look if
but but there can be there are legal
reasons why you can sort of hedge that a
little bit which is if he's up there
screaming kill the Jews were hanging
black people now there now there's a
criminal part to this right a call to
violence right but short of that I think
you have to let these I think you've
said it somewhere I read a quote in
something about that if you just if you
stifle these people you always make them
stronger I mean that's sort of right and
I think that there's also there's also
this weird line that you end up creating
there's a youtuber I forget his real
name but he goes by the name of count
Dane Dane Kula count dank EULA and he is
yes yes I know the work of countess yes
is no but and he's he's having to go and
I don't know if it got postponed I know
it's supposed to be sometime around
right around now but he's facing jail
time because he put out a video of him
jokingly making his dog do the Nazi
salute facing jail time where what I
believe well is it is it Scotland okay
but it's not the United States so that's
why I like you yeah elsewhere yeah and
you're like oh [ __ ] you see what
happened right and so it's like and so
that's why you end up caring about the
line right of holding on something
because then it becomes that which I
will say it's distasteful in context
it's it was a really stupid joke because
his whole argument was his girlfriend
loves the dog so much that he wants to
ruin the dog and so the best way to ruin
something is to make it a Nazi right in
context it's like okay yeah but but then
outside of that there's there such a
negative feeling that when when do you
start doing things that are just
ridiculous
yeah like the fact that he's facing jail
time I think is ridiculous I'm open to
other people being sensitive about it
being offended by it but the fact that a
court can go that's illegal
that's crazy yeah and so I think that's
why I try to at all times understand
that that free speech should be that
open no matter how despicable we think
it is yeah not the dog the actual Nazis
just sucks like it just and that's what
that's the part of the conversation that
I think people are always afraid to have
like we're all everyone if you ask
anyone there are you for free speech yes
but then the second you get them to a
place that's uncomfortable for them then
they say well that's the one that's the
one I can't write but it's like yeah it
really is sucky but you can't be up that
you can't be calling for violence you
can't obviously be committing violence
but short of that you gotta let people
do otherwise you actually make them the
victim which is what they really want
more than anything else you know they
want to trade in that victimhood and
that's I don't want to trade in that
bill DeFranco I feel I should leave you
to your to your wife
yeah well I don't know unless unless
your producer is the worst person in the
world I don't think she had the baby we
said we were going to give you a fair
warning whatever they felt this was so
gripping so gripping that you have
another key that I've missed my shot by
the birth of my child yeah I would have
to make everything I do from here on out
to destroy your show from Oh a great
promo for you but actually that would be
great you do what you got to do I'm so
glad we finally did this now I know I'm
gonna bump into you halfway down the
street probably maybe one day if I ever
go outside yeah but now you got this
indoor bike too yeah so I get to just
stay inside air-conditioned since I
lived in I've lived in California for
like seven years and a hundred degrees
is just unbearable to me yeah it's it's
made me so weak all right well it was a
pleasure which I expected it to be and
for more on Phil you
can find him making sense of the madness
is that too much pressure no I like it
might be made slogan he's making sense
of the madness on the philip defranco
show which is right here on the YouTube
[Music]
you
[Music]